how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything mcu the hype of spider-man 3
is real it's so real and big that it
looks like we have
another negotiation for spider-man
between sony and marvel studios disney
now i'm sure most of you remember the
recent negotiations between sony and
disney that we had not too long ago that
put
everybody on edge and everybody was
really afraid that spider-man was going
to be
out of the mcu now ultimately that
wasn't the case
sony and marvel came to a deal and
spider-man is still in the mcu but it
does appear like we have a new deal
in the works right now so this is coming
from two different sources and the first
one is mikey sutton gegossity.com if you
recall
mikey was an insider during the last
negotiations between sony and disney he
kept us up to date with what was really
happening
and his report today says that disney
and sony are on the verge of a new deal
for
spider-man's rights but no need to fear
as this is
actually good news this could actually
mean more spider-man film collaborations
between sony and marvel
and new live-action tv shows as well
possibly
on disney plus the report says details
are scarce but sources say the deal will
keep spider-man in the marvel cinematic
universe for an additional
three solo movies with an option for
more
this would mean that we would get out of
the spider-man homecoming trilogy era
which is set during peter parker's high
school years
and move on to peter parker's college
years all of course
meanwhile being a part of the avengers
possibly going on to
lead the avengers or the young avengers
then we also have another report from
the dis
insider hearing the same exact rumor
they said on their podcast that marvel
studios
extended the spider-man deal with sony
due to the web slinger playing a pivotal
role
in the future of the marvel cinematic
universe now the fact that sony and
disney are working a new deal doesn't
really come as that big of a surprise
as things heat up for spider-man 3 more
and more people are getting more and
more excited for it
each and every day and it seems like
every day a new report comes out for
spider-man 3 that gets the fans super
pumped
and right now it's kind of all anybody
can really talk about so of course tom
holland has a very
huge role in the marvel cinematic
universe moving forward
after spider-man 3 especially if you
consider what's going to happen in
spider-man 3 with
the multiverse and right now if the
reports for tom holland's current
contract
are accurate that means he only has one
more solo film
and a group film left with the contract
between sony and disney
and even though spider-man 3 is looking
to be a very very big movie with many
different characters that's going to be
his solo film
then he'll most likely be in a new
avengers film and that's going to be it
and that's all going to be within the
next few years which isn't a very long
future in the marvel cinematic universe
so again it comes as no surprise that
they're striking a new deal
and of course they're doing it right now
because the hype for spider-man 3
is getting bigger and bigger every day
so they want to get this deal locked
down before the release of spider-man 3
because there is so much more potential
with spider-man in the marvel cinematic
universe than we already have
there's many different routes that they
can go down in the movies but also on
disney plus
he can appear in many of the different
series that are going to be coming down
the line
plus not to mention when kevin feige
during the investor day was talking
about the upcoming disney plus series
she-hulk he revealed that tatiana
maslany is going to be playing she-hulk
jennifer walters and he did reveal that
mark ruffalo will be in the series as
well as the hulk
along with a bunch of other people who
might show
up well we know that peter is going to
need a lawyer at some point because of
the events that happened in spider-man
far from home
so perhaps she could show up in
spider-man 3 and then spider-man could
show up in the she-hulk disney plus
series
and not to mention they'll probably want
tom holland's spider-man to show up in
the secret invasion disney plus show
that was recently announced nick fury
and talos are going to be in the show
and the last time we saw talos he was
with spider-man who we thought was nick
fury the entire time helping spider-man
slash peter parker out ended up actually
being
talos and his wife so there's definitely
a president for tom hall and spider-man
to be
in that series and marvel and disney
probably want to use him in a series
like that in other series as well
which is probably why we're getting this
new deal so they can put tom holland
spider-man
in more projects for marvel studios and
at the end of the day it works out
better for marvel
and sony because they all make money
and of course that's what it's about and
tom holland staying
within the marvel cinematic universe so
unlike
last time this is actually a good thing
that a new deal between sony and disney
marvel studios is being worked out for
tom holland spider-man
in the marvel cinematic universe what
future projects would you like to see
tom holland spider-man in let me know
your thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all things mcu and so you can enter this
week's giveaway for a chance to win a
tony stark quantum suit funko pop i am
picking a winner tomorrow
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof